heroes and villains always have the same
backstory pain the difference is what
they choose to do about it villain says
the world heard me I'll hurt it back the
hero says the world heard me I'm not
gonna let it hurt anybody else Heroes
use pain villains are used by it one of
the things for people who are not where
they wanna be is that they have pain and
I remember when I was starting out I was
looking for passion I was looking for
purpose I was like I just want to find
something that I'm motivated by but it's
the cat in the cheese it's like we're
looking for cheese but we have all these
cat behind us and all we have to do is
look and remember that they're behind us
and chasing us if you have the cat and
you're staying in your current situation
you're being used by the cat you're
being used by the business owner who
doesn't treat you well and you're in
this job they don't really want to be in
versus saying like this is terrible and
because of this terribleness I now have
something that I can run away from
rather than not looking at the knife or
trying to take painkillers to not feel
the pain it's like completely sobering
up taking the knife and twisting it in
your own heart and being like I'm gonna
do something about this